the michael scott foundation
is still in existence there you are i
don't think we have finished with my
inbox
what's scott's tots
has it really been 10 years a local
businessman pledges college tuition to
third graders
mr scott i know you're a busy man and
your schedule moves around a lot
but for all your generosity through the
years your tots
who are ready to graduate thought it was
time to give you a proper
thank you
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do
make your dreams come true hey mrs scott
what you gonna do
what you gonna do to make your dreams
come true you came into a loss and made
a promise that made the sinus
made us realize we don't need to
compromise because we
have it all cause you made it possible
for us to achieve an improbable
hey
hey mr scott what you gonna do what you
gonna do make your dreams come true
let's put your hands together and give a
warm welcome for the man of the hour mr
michael scott
all right wow um
i am never going to forget today not a
chance
i don't think i could ever give back to
you what you have given me today
who here's done something stupid in
their lives like skipped out on study
hall
or mix up the difference between a jim
and b jim that sort of thing
show of hands anybody yes bunch of you
okay
well me too i've done something stupid
which i would like to share
um
should we go no no we're okay it's a
double period
all right i came here today because i
promised you tuition
and tuition is very valuable but you
know what's invaluable
is intuition you know what that is that
is the ability
to know when something is about to
happen
does anybody out there have intuition
know what's gonna happen next
nobody okay you're gonna make me say it
all right i am so proud of all of you
derek and leferve and and ben and ayanna
and michaela
and nikki and jason and i'm
sorry okay so are spacing your name i'm
zion that's mckayla's younger brother
well zion i am not going to be paying
for your tuition
[Laughter]
which brings me to my main point and
that is that i will not be able to pay
for anybody's tuition
i'm so so sorry hold on
now i can't pay for your college
but you don't have to go to class
to be in class online courses
are a viable option to a traditional
college experience
and the best way to access those courses
is with your own
personal laptop which is rendered
useless without batteries and i have one
for each of you
hold on hold on hold on hold on they're
lithium
and that is a perfect match this is
crazy
why would parlov send himself a death
threat for publicity
i mean he was on tv his book is on the
bestseller list for the first time in
years harlow doesn't need any help
he's already famous rich he's got more
babes than he can handle come on that
guy
now you're just lying to prove a point
he pulls jake he pulls
ugh look i know how it is it can be
disappointing to meet your hero
i'm just like me and patrick ewing you
said that went great i lied it was a
disaster
excuse me mr ewing my name is jake
peralta
hey you're my favorite player you
pantsing patrick ewing has nothing to do
with this
it doesn't oh my god why did i share
that story nice work sarge
you were right who cares about parlov
we write our own stories so welcome to
the terry chronicles
book one the arrest of edmond grail
followed by book two the ravishing of
sharon
i am so sorry i'm just pumped that you
showed up i couldn't let you down
and that is why you're my hero come on
bring it in big fella oh no
it happened again it happened again
terry
you my friend are ready to go dancing
thank you sir
all right next andrew looking good
business is booming yeah hey ron how
about you need a little dog waxing
it's only five bucks and i'll let you
cut in front of this guy what come on
beat it this is ron swanson we're
talking about
i'm impressed with andy pulling himself
up by his bootstraps
it reminds me of me i got my first job
when i was nine worked at a sheet metal
factory
in two weeks i was running the floor
child labor laws are ruining this
country
do you have a key in your shoe no no i
have a bunion that's practically its own
toe
normally the pain howls through my
loafers like a banshee on the moors but
for these past three minutes it's been
reduced to a faint growl
okay that's neat
well hey we are all finished
well oh that was great
thank you son no sweat
next you shouldn't let your friends cut
in line it's not good business oh you
know what else is in good business
that guy's my friend right
i'm saying you shouldn't let your
friends cut in line all right sorry kyle
here doing this
next you ever understood the term elbow
grease
i guess it's not really grease just hard
work
oh hey ron nice shiny shoes you got
there oh hey i was just um
i think oh no shoot actually it looks
like i scuffed this one
do you need your money background cause
i already spent it really
how did never mind uh
i think i'll just take another full
polish
can i cut in line again i feel right at
home as a shoe shine
i have no idea what i'm doing but i know
i'm doing it really really well
third time today
that's a good shoeshine
what the [ __ ] man i i don't know
what happened frankly
i emitted a noise the noise was
involuntary
sometimes a sound is just a sound you
know
no i haven't been back i wish him
good luck in his business and yes i will
absolutely
go back to get my shoes shined
soon i don't frankly see why this
is a topic for discussion
oh hey ron what's up
uh andy
you know the uh the thing
the other day the other day the other
day yeah
oh uh yesterday i am
that was that was i feel like i'm okay
you know i'd be okay if we
i'd be okay if we never mentioned it
again
never mentioned what again
the moan ron the weird moan you made
that was super weird
do you not remember that i talked about
it with a lady who went after you for a
half an hour
she said she thought it was an am okay
it was just an odd moment let's just
let's just not talk about it ah
that's what i was trying to say but yeah
okay
okay good time
you